[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition 100% Sénat pour suivre
aujourd'hui une audition de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur la
pénurie des médicaments en France vous
le savez il y a actuellement plus de
3000 références impactées par ces
pénuries contre seulement 700
médicaments en 2018 et donc cette
semaine ce sont 5 représentants de
cabinet de conseils qui étaient reçus au
Sénat je propose d'écouter ses échanges
la première question vous l'avez
souligné plus ou moins chacun dans vos
propos liminaires c'est qu'effectivement
depuis une trentaine d'années il y a une
politique de délocalisation
des entreprises et notamment
pharmaceutiques mais pas que mais pour
ce qui nous intéresse on va dire
pharmaceutique des localisations donc
dans d'autres pays pour des raisons
les auditions l'ont fait ressortir pour
des raisons de rentabilité on va dire
optimale puisque les
normes sociales et environnementales
étaient on va dire moins exigeante dans
d'autres pays que dans que en France ou
ou en Europe donc moi je voudrais que
vous me disiez de manière extrêmement
précise
est-ce que vous en tant que donc cabinet
conseil vous avez conseillé à une
entreprise d'externalisée ou de
délocaliser de telles activités de
production et pratiquement le
le corollaire on va dire à cette
question c'est que quel a été votre
appréciation sur la fiscalité pour
conseiller les délocalisations et
notamment en balance qu'elle
appréciation vous avez pu avoir sur les
aides publiques je pense notamment aussi
donc ça c'est les deux questions qui
sont du même ordre peut-être que je vais
vous laisser y répondre et j'enchaînerai
par des questions sur les prix
pour ça que
à question précise réponse précise et
qui se conçoit bien s'énonce bien comme
on dit Monsieur Lopez
comme je vous l'avais dit en fait sur la
question vraiment très industrielle nous
c'est pas un de nos cœurs d'activité
néanmoins c'est quand même des sujets
qui peuvent émerger dans des discussions
avec notre client notamment de ce que en
fait quand il y a une question
d'implantation d'un site il y a une
question de compétition entre pays donc
la question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
met en valeur les atouts qui sont ceux
de notre territoire pour les faire
valoir à la maison mère
après la question de la décision de la
maison mère et de son rationnel souvent
elle nous échappe alors après de manière
un peu pragmatique ça peut être très
accès sur la problématique fiscale et la
France a pas une aura très positive sur
le sujet notamment moi je travaille pour
beaucoup de clients
étrangers notamment américain qui a une
sorte potentiellement d'épidermie par
rapport à la complexité aux millefeuille
en fait de taxation en France notamment
quand il
vont jusqu'au bout du cheminement en se
disant bon bah si j'investis de l'argent
pour produire en France et qu'ensuite je
vais être confronté à une négociation de
prix extrêmement
dur et difficile à comprendre pour moi
et après il peut y avoir un enchaînement
en fait de taxes et de contribution qui
va venir s'ajouter là dessus
je dois mettre que pour les convaincre
c'est pas forcément évident donc il y a
quand même une une sorte aussi des fois
d'image un peu préconçue sur la France
c'est compliqué
moi c'est ce que je constate de
l'expérience que j'ai eu pour avoir
essayé de défendre en fait des soit des
implantations soit des extensions de
sites
en France notamment de recherche pour ma
part c'est le peu de regard que j'ai sur
le sujet
très bien merci Monsieur Plantevin
question précise réponse précise nous
n'avons pas travaillé sur des
problématiques de délocalisation de site
industriel en France sur les 5 dernières
années nous avons travaillé sur des
problématiques de
spécialisation de sites pour répondre à
des besoins déficients
conscients que certaines de nos clients
faisaient un peu de tout partout ce qui
générait de la complexité de la perte
d'efficacité et donc on a effectivement
travaillé sur des problématiques de
comment res spécialiser des sites sur un
certain nombre de technologies de type
de produits pour draguer de l'efficience
il n'y avait aucune considération de
délocalisation
très bien
je me souviens
même chose réponse question précise
réponse précise
sur les délocalisations non à ma
connaissance nous ne sommes pas
intervenus sur des sujets qui auraient
eu pour conséquence directe des
délocalisations de site industriels en
France au cours des cinq dernières
années vous avez également posé la
question de l'externalisation
et donc je mets le sujet également de
manière très précise sur la table oui
nous sommes intervenus sur un sujet qui
peut être considéré comme une
externalisation mais sur laquelle on
pourra revenir qui est que nous avons
travaillé en amont de la création
d'euros API puis ensuite en aval sur la
mise en œuvre de roapi voilà
deux trois éléments également très
précis de notre côté comme je le vous le
disais la focalisation de travaux pour
l'industrie sur des problématiques de
manufacturing en France et vraiment
focalisé sur ces notions de renforcement
de la base industriel de développement
des capacités de production
d'amélioration de la compétitivité et du
positionnement de ces sites en France ce
qui contribue à leur maintien en France
donc ça c'est premier élément deuxième
élément à ma connaissance et dans l'état
de l'avancement de notre collègue de
données qui est déjà bien avancé nous
n'avons pas accompagné de projets de
délocalisation ou de fermeture ou
d'exernalisation de sites en France
ça peut être un effet connexe
propos de mes collègues
nous ne sommes pas intervenus
directement dans ces enjeux de
délocalisation et de choix
industrialisation malgré tout
nous avons travaillé sur des réflexions
autour de renforcement de l'attractivité
de la France notamment dans le choix que
mentionné monsieur Lopez tout à l'heure
de cette compétition interpellie et donc
effectivement dans la prise en compte
des critères de d'investissement
industriels ou autre on a différents
thématiques qui interviennent alors vous
mentionnez à la thématique fiscale
réglementaire effectivement elle fait
partie d'une d'un environnement
économique qui sous-tende n'importe
quelle décision d'investissement c'est
une décision d'investissement qui ont
qui représente des sommes importantes
donc effectivement la question de
l'environnement réglementaire fiscal est
posée
mais à côté de celle-ci vous avez aussi
des vraies questions autour de la
capacité à créer ou avoir des emplois ou
des compétences de filière de santé
disponible dans le territoire qui permet
de rassurer en fait un investisseur ou
un laboratoire dans la capacité chorale
pays à doté
l'usine de des bonnes ressources et à
permettre le bon développement ça c'est
un élément important
mentionner tout à l'heure le
millefeuille effectivement parfois cette
surtransposition cette multitude de
complexité réglementaire pose malgré
tout de questions sur la capacité même
s'il y a des efforts qui ont été faits
une simplification qui a été fait
parfois pour certaines questions sur la
capacité du choix le troisième sujet sur
lequel la France est vraiment sans
relativement grandissent les
infrastructures la capacité
logistiquement de pouvoir transporter un
médicament sur l'ensemble du territoire
la capacité à bénéficier de soins
d'unité de soins de qualité pour pouvoir
administrer en fait les différents les
différents médicaments
et enfin il y a une problématique et une
problématique aussi de
d'optimisation du maillage du territoire
pour être sûr que dans la manière dont
le soin est organisé on arrive à mettre
les bons moyens aux bons endroits et
donc on a souvent été confronté en
France à cette problématique de
saupoudrage d'investissement un peu
partout après vous posez une question
très précise sur le crédit pour
recherche effectivement c'est
aujourd'hui dans l'analyse qu'on avait
pu faire un vrai outil de
différenciation de la France
et qui est un outil important dans la
capacité quel territoire aujourd'hui à
venir atterrir attirer un certain nombre
d'investissement
très bien merci
vous avez été le seul monsieur Gauthier
à répondre sur le fait que effectivement
le cire était un excellent outil je
crois que quand je vous parle de la
fiscalité il faut il faut prendre en
compte que au niveau des aides publiques
la France est numéro un donc là je l'ai
pas entendu dans vos autres propos c'est
ma première réflexion par rapport à mes
questions ma deuxième réflexion
s'adresse à Monsieur Plantevin est-ce
que
c'est vous enfin votre votre cabinet
conseil puisque nous avons comme vous le
savez notamment
auditionner Sanofi est-ce que c'est vous
qui avez conseillé à Sanofi de quelques
en quelque sorte réduire la voilure
Aramon et Sisteron ou non justement de
la spécialisation c'est ma deuxième ma
deuxième remarque et puis quand je
parlais de délocalisation c'est quand
même
une stratégie de la France pas
d'ailleurs que de la France vous l'avez
vous l'avez noté c'est une stratégie
aussi qui s'est joué au niveau européen
vous dites non on n'a pas conseillé en
termes de délocalisation est-ce que
est-ce que dans ce que vous dites si je
comprends bien ça veut dire que vous
n'avez même pas
émis des conseils concernant des
délocalisations partielles par exemple
de technologie et de production au motif
de l'efficience
parce que j'ai bien compris
directement et on va refaire le tour
vous en profiter pour répondre aux
autres questions en même temps je vous
remercie merci Madame la rapporteur vous
comprendrez que dans une audition
publique où on citera pas le nom de nos
clients mais je vais répondre à votre
question nous n'avons pas travaillé pour
Sanofi sur cette sur ces sites que vous
évoquez là donc
non plus
sur la les problématiques de
délocalisation je vais répéter ce que je
disais précédemment
nous n'avons pas effectivement
travailler sur
de la délocalisation de site en France
sur les cinq dernières années et donc
voilà je me permets de reformuler est-ce
que dans vos conseils il y a plus y
avoir dans les conséquences une
délocalisation ou une stratégie
industrielle qui a fait que le paysage
tel qu'il était constitué a été modifiée
et donc même si vous n'avez pas donné le
conseil de délocaliser vos conseils ont
pu entraîner par la suite ces événements
là en sachant que vos clients sont des
clients inscrits dans le temps et donc
forcément l'interaction est régulière et
donc vous êtes forcément au courant de
ce qui a pu se passer même si il y a pas
d'accusation de liens directs il y a
cependant les conséquences indirectes
merci pour votre la position de votre
question donc
le
focus de notre activité en servant les
Big Pharma en particulier se concentrent
essentiellement sur leurs produits
innovants ou leurs nouveaux produits
nous avons assez peu intervenus sur des
problématiques de produits matures et
le focus de la politique de
délocalisation ou d'externalisation
comme l'évoquait monsieur virtbaï plutôt
sur les produits matures donc
dans le cadre du spectre de
d'intervention que nous avons fait pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique en France je
ne vois pas de lien direct entre les
recommandations que nous aurions pu
faire et des conséquences industrielles
de délocalisation
sur les cinq dernières années
c'est Lopez
la même manière en fait on travaille
quasiment jamais en fait sur des
produits nature sur des enjeux qui sont
liés aux produits nature contre les
clients nous appellent c'est justement
pour des lancements de produits donc
c'est des nouveaux produits des
nouvelles technologies des innovations
est-ce que eux considéré en tout cas
comme des innovations qui sont souvent
pas produits en France
voir ni même en Europe donc le sujet en
fait de l'outil productif tel qu'il est
ou tel qui va devenir nous c'est un
sujet qui sur lequel on
interagit quasiment jamais le seul sujet
sur lequel on peut interagir c'est sur
notamment des éléments de régulation
mais je pense que vous y viendrez après
par le comité économique qui peuvent eux
toucher des produits qui ont déjà eu une
vie ça c'est un autre sujet en fait
pour ma part non puisque c'est un moment
dans la phase du médicament où les deux
sont les innovation et le médicament
mature sur la fixation du prix
oui oui
je pense que ça fait partie de d'une
autre partie de l'audition monsieur
c'est très difficile de retracer
précisément mais je pense que même
indirectement je ma connaissance je ne
vois pas de choix ou de travaux que nous
ayons pu faire stratégique qui peut
avoir une conséquence soit sur des
transferts de technologie soit sur des
transferts de volume soit sur des
transferts de sites de production que ce
soit sur des produits matures ou voir
innovants
oui oui
parce que j'ai ce que j'ai posé comme
question concernant les le fait que les
aides publiques sont soit très
généreuses en France que donc ça fait
partie d'atouts
on revient enfin pour répondre à cette
question je n'ai pas adressé ce point-là
qui est effectivement un point important
je pense que l'attractivité de d'une
localisation industrielle dépend d'un
certain nombre de facteurs comme vous
l'évoquez il y a des facteurs fiscaux
évidemment et d'aide publique comme le
comme le cire il y a des facteurs de
compétences et d'infrastructures il y a
des facteurs de prix et des facteurs de
coût de matières premières je pense que
les les choix de localisation sont
effectivement très multi dimensionnelles
et qui a un certain nombre d'atouts en
France vous citez le SIR et d'une
certaine partie du cadre fiscal je pense
que les infrastructures également sont
de bonne qualité je pense que les
compétences techniques sont également de
très bonne qualité je pense que
l'énergie aujourd'hui c'est un élément
important est assez compétit donc je
pense qu'il y a un certain nombre
effectivement de d'éléments positifs en
France et il y a également des éléments
négatifs qui ont été cités nombreuses
reprises lors de de vos différentes
auditions donc absolument je reconnais
ce que vous dites sur le fait qu'il y a
qu'on a des avantages importants en
France
et également des désavantages sur un
certain nombre de points
je partage absolument ce qui vient
d'être dit sur les facteurs de
compétitivité de la France je pense ce
type de mécanisme peuvent absolument en
faire partie
et les notions effectivement de
disponibilités de compétences sur le sol
français et productivité aussi des sites
des sites en France etc sont des
éléments d'attractivité du territoire
français donc ça c'est premier élément
deuxième élément sur la fiscalité
nos principes nous interdisent nous
interdisons de donner des conseils à nos
clients sur des éléments fiscaux ça ne
fait pas partie des
du périmètre des conseils que nous
sommes habilités à donner à nos clients
donc ça c'est deuxième élément et
troisième élément encore une fois à ma
connaissance je ne sers pas directement
les acteurs de l'industrie sur ces
sujets mais néanmoins à ma connaissance
et encore une fois sur la base de la
collecte d'information je n'ai pas
identifié de projets qui directement ont
indirectement amen à de la délorisation
ou
du transfert de technologie
donc j'aurai la même réponse en termes
de projet sur la liste des études qu'on
a préparé en fait aujourd'hui il y a pas
de projet directement liés à ces
analyses après peut-être juste pour
mettre un peu les choses en perspective
quand on travaille sur le renforcement
de la compétitivité d'un acteur en
France effectivement il y a un certain
nombre d'arbitrage qui sont faits
aujourd'hui pour se dire où se trouve et
où comment l'acteur peut maximiser et
créer la meilleure valeur possible et
donc forcément nous nos travaux nous
conduisent généralement à aider les
acteurs à déterminer les meilleurs
poches de marché en fait pour pouvoir
être au meilleur niveau de compétitivité
pour être au bon niveau de compétitivité
naturellement un moment il y a un
certain nombre d'arbitrages qui peuvent
être fait de manière indirecte à nouveau
qui sont des
arbitrages qui peuvent être des
arbitrages de spécialisation à un moment
pour être sûr d'être au bon niveau de
compétitivité sur les sujets les plus
importants et qui peuvent pas ricochet
un moment avoir un impact sur ce que
pourrait être des molécules moins
performantes sur un certain nombre de
sujet donc message je dirais que c'est
une évolution classique
en économique dans la mesure où quelque
part les entreprises au moment une
logique de développement d'une partie de
leurs activités
donc j'ai bien entendu que ma kinés ne
donne pas de conseils fiscaux
j'aimerais bien savoir si les autres
cabinets en donnent et puis je suis un
petit peu dubitative on va dire parce
que on peut jouer comme ça au chat et à
la souris dans les questions pour les
repréciser ça joue un peu la montre mais
j'ai bien noté que quand même les choix
de localisation ou de rester sur le
territoire
dépend effectivement de nombreux
facteurs on n'apprend pas avec vous avec
votre audition ça a été dit tout au long
des auditions que nous avons commencé
depuis plusieurs mois puis on a une
petite culture sur le sujet on le savait
déjà mais justement
ces choix de localisation qui sont
multifactorielles
bien il y a des il y a des atouts pour
la France et je pense qu'en tant que
cabinet conseil vous hiérarchiser les
atouts
me semble-t-il et que parmi les atouts
que vous pouvez hiérarchiser
il me semble pas aberrant de penser
qu'il y a la notion de fiscalité
alors si c'est pour préciser ma question
parce qu'elle était floue je la précise
et on peut comme ça faire une cascade de
clarification mais je pense que c'est
important que vous alliez au bout de vos
réponses comme j'essaye de clarifier
mais mes questions si elles ne sont pas
suffisamment suffisamment clair et je
vais continuer pour que on va faire des
on va faire des des questions au moins
par deux pour permettre après à mes
collègues de pouvoir de pouvoir poser
également des questions mais j'aimerais
que vous puissiez nous dire si vous avez
conseillé en dehors des
des industries donc aider laboratoires
pharmaceutiques est-ce que vous avez
conseillé des entités publiques
et évidemment du secteur de la santé et
ayant très à la souveraineté
sanitaire donc quand je parle d'entités
publiques pour que nous soyons
extrêmement clair et que ma question
soit mieux comprises je parle à la fois
au niveau des ministères que ce soit le
ministère de la santé ou le ministère de
l'Industrie par exemple pour ne prendre
que des exemples mais pour que mon sujet
soit bien clair et bien cadré évidemment
quand je parle du ministère de la Santé
je pense aussi aux agences qui en
dépendent je vais pas toutes vous les
citer mais vous les avez bien en tête
donc j'aimerais bien avoir de ce point
de vue là des réponses à mes questions
et puis est-ce que vous avez
conseillé des structures hospitalières
je pense à l'AP-HP mais il n'y a pas que
la PHP il y a la PHM il y en a plein
d'autres ou des fédérations
hospitalières et y compris les centrales
d'achat chat donc sur quel point et sur
quel montant
peut-être que là mes questions sont plus
précises donc plus compréhensibles on
atteint un seuil de précision assez
correcte monsieur Lopez
c'est effectivement très très précis et
là et la réponse est va être très
précise c'est non en fait parce que
le domaine d'activité par exemple de
conseils hospitalier
touche je pense à des cabinets qui sont
pas présents ici c'est pareil c'est des
structures qui sont très spécialisés
dans l'organisation hospitalière de
structures hospitalières en tout cas
nous on fait pas et
conseils vers des ministères non plus
donc pour être très précis pas pour ma
part en tout cas à ma connaissance
ça fait de nombreuses années que Ben a
fait un choix de ne pas servir le
secteur public donc
nous nous sommes pas intervenus auprès
de différentes instances
gouvernementales ou ministériel ou
d'autorité régionale on a fait un projet
en fait pour le ministère de la Santé le
ministère de l'Industrie c'était ce
qu'on appelle un projet pro bono
c'est-à-dire gratuit pour accompagner le
ministère de l'Industrie et de la santé
dans la montée en capacité des tests
covid en préparation de confinement en
avril 2020
avec une vraie conscience d'aider le
pays à sortir du confinement et il y
avait trois grands sujets le premier
c'était la montée en capacité de la
capacité à délivrer du test le deuxième
c'était concentré se concentrer sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement d'un
certain nombre de produits absolument
critiques allant de choses très simples
telles que des écouvillants
jusqu'à l'accompagnement de société de
biotech ou startup délivrant aux
produisant des tests covid qui pouvaient
potentiellement accompagner le
gouvernement dans sa montée en capacité
en sortie en sortie de confinement
réponse également
précise autant que je peux l'activité
secteur public est une activité très
minime pour nous c'est moins de 1% de
notre chiffre d'affaires sur le secteur
de la
de la santé en service public
ce ne sont pas des projets que moi-même
je suis pour des raisons de séparation
entre nos activités privées et nos
activités publiques à ma connaissance
nous avons réalisé je crois trois
projets au cours des des cinq dernières
années et à ma connaissance également
aucun fut lié à la à la souveraineté
sanitaire voilà
pour plus de précisions de je devrais
vous
revenir par écrit
alors en ce qui nous concerne on a un
secteur public et un secteur d'activité
en santé publique qui est substantielle
on a eu l'occasion de d'accompagner un
certain nombre d'acteurs publics on a
travaillé avec un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux publics notamment sur des
principalement sur des sujets
d'amélioration des parcours de prise en
charge des patients d'amélioration
opérationnelle du fonctionnement des
hôpitaux on a travaillé aussi pas mal
sur des sujets d'innovation notamment au
développement d'institut hospitalot
universitaire par exemple
on a également travaillé avec un centre
d'autorité de santé
notamment sur la mise en œuvre de la des
aspects logistique de la campagne de
vaccination
il y a quelques temps
et on a fourni d'ailleurs l'année
dernière une liste très complète de
l'ensemble des travaux qu'on a pu
effectuer dans le champ dans le champ
public
donc je serais ravi de vous le refaire
passer j'ai pas forcément tout en tête
mais de mémoire
et on pourra vous repréciser ça j'ai pas
mémoire là qu'on est vraiment travaillé
sur des sur des sujets de souveraineté
sanitaires
après le sujet de l'acquisition
d'enquête la souveraineté c'est une des
portes d'entrée on est bien sur la
pénurie de médicaments et là pour le
coup les questions de logistique
interviennent forcément et donc quand on
parle d'approvisionnement
il me semble que c'est lié
mais du coup quelle est la question
spécifique pas à propos éventuellement
de ces voilà de ces appuis là
développer Larousse oui je vais prendre
la parole parce qu'effectivement au
moins sur la partie qui concerne nos
activités auprès du secteur public dont
j'ai donc j'ai la charge au sein de
syndrome lamberger à Paris donc pour ce
qui concerne Roland burger il y a eu
trois accompagnements sur les cinq
dernières années qui concernent la
sphère que vous évoquez le premier
concerne un inconvénient pour l'AP-HP
sur des sujets d'optimisation du
fonctionnement interne en dehors de
l'activité de santé donc l'activité de
restauration l'activité d'hébergement
l'activité de lingerie donc ça c'est un
travail qu'on a fait pour la PHP un
deuxième travail qui a été fait au tout
début de la prise covid en pro-boneau
pour la PHP en a mis à disposition un
certain nombre de nos consultants pour
aider la PHP à des à des choses très
simples simplement il y avait des des
appareils médicaux qui arrivaient sur le
parvis des hôpitaux à Paris il fallait
des individus pour les aider à les
dispatcher dans le au sein de au sein
des hôpitaux donc on a on a on a
accompagné la PHP sur ce sujet sans sans
facturation et enfin un dernier projet
on a accompagné on a mis à disposition
des équipes en l'occurrence quelques
personnes une ou deux sur la durée de la
crise covid au sein du ministère de la
Santé pour les aider au sein de la
cellule de crise à gérer tout un tas de
sujets je serais bien en peine d'évoquer
là un par un mais on pourra mettre à
votre disposition les consultants qui
ont travaillé spécifiquement qui
pourront dire précisément ce qu'ils ont
fait dans le cadre de cette de cette
crise covid voilà les trois projets qui
concernent la sphère que vous évoquez
oui vous comprenez bien que à partir du
moment où vous intervenez au niveau donc
des entités publiques notamment les
hôpitaux et que vous êtes amené vous
avez été amené à intervenir au niveau
notamment de la crise covid vous êtes
vous avez sans doute été amenés et c'est
les précisions que je souhaiterais
notamment avoir
outre celle qu'on peut avoir en notre
possession par rapport à une autre
commission d'enquête donc ça va les
informations circulent entre nous mais
c'est la notion des stocks par exemple
est-ce que vous avez été amené à
travailler sur ces questions et à
conseiller vos clients en matière en
matière de stock parce que ça c'est un
lien direct avec les pénuries les
pénuries de médicaments et puis mettez
donc cette question
un peu au chaud et j'enchaîne sur le
fait que plusieurs d'entre vous ont dit
qu'effectivement ils allaient nous
donner des précisions notamment sur leur
intervention concernant la fixation des
prix et
la négociation des prix des médicaments
nous avons reçu vous avez peut-être vous
l'avez peut-être vu la société
igvia et si on va sur son site on peut
voir un certain nombre de de conseils
qu'il prodigue alors à leurs clients
donc vous de quelle manière vous êtes
intervenu pour obtenir le meilleur prix
possible pour les médicaments et puis je
vais un petit peu plus loin est-ce qu'il
vous est arrivé en fait de négocier ou
de participer plus exactement
directement au négociations avec le CEPS
donc là la réponse va être oui
est-ce que ça c'est un peu mon coeur
d'activité donc pour comprendre le sujet
il y a effectivement
quand les clients viennent vers nous
pour savoir
quelle pourrait être l'horizon de ce qui
pourrait se compter en France il y en a
une partie d'entre eux qui ont pas
forcément d'expertise sur le sujet donc
ils ont besoin d'un décryptage d'une
part des étapes ensuite dans un
accompagnement dans les étapes d'autres
sont présents en France peut être des
très grosses structures mais pas
forcément une pratique
répétitive et quotidienne du sujet
d'évaluation et de négociation ce sur
quoi on peut aussi nous les aider en
fait à les actualiser sur et les
pratiques et ce à quoi ils peuvent
s'attendre
donc dans ce cadre là en fait on va
d'une part les aider à pour ce qui est
des étapes d'évaluation
à présenter de manière correcte et telle
qu'elle est attendue par par la chass en
fait lors de mes clinique
et ça ça va donner lieu effectivement à
une évaluation
SMS comparateur que le comité économique
va ensuite utiliser pour
la fixation de son prix et dans la
fixation du prix il y a quand même de
composantes il y a le prix faciale donc
ce que vous voyez sur les boîtes et qui
peut des fois paraître extrêmement cher
puis à toute la face de régulation et
donc de primette et il y a une vraie
dissymétrie entre ce qu'on voit sur la
boîte et ce qui est réellement payé par
la collectivité on regarde des
régulations en fait qui se font et à
l'entrée et ensuite durant toute la vie
du produit
donc ça oui effectivement nous on a nos
clients il y a un point important c'est
que des gens on les aide à comprendre
qui vont peut-être pas obtenir ce qui
ont en tête au départ il y a quand même
un gros travail de pédagogie notamment
pour les firmes étrangères
de leur expliquer quel est le champ des
possibles les champs des possibles en
France il est clairement délimité en
fait par l'évaluation has et ensuite les
critères sur lesquels le comité
économique se fixe pour décider du
niveau des prix et c'est très souvent
les comparateurs et le prix des
comparateurs
et là il y a forcément des désillusions
parce qu'en fait quand vous faites tout
un développement clinique dans une
maladie qui est très peu de temps
alternatif thérapeutique mais votre
comparateur
c'est
je prends quelque chose de très peu cher
corticostéroïde
la base de la négociation elle va partir
de là quand même et ça peut être un peu
déceptif quand même
et donc mieux vaut les prévenir au début
ensuite leur expliquer s'il y a des
alternatives à ça ou pas et si oui
lesquels elles sont en fait pour qu'ils
puissent élaborer d'une part une vision
de ce qu'ils vont obtenir et ensuite
c'est d'y arriver
et donc nous on intervient pas
directement auprès du Comité économique
moi je conseille mes clients et ensuite
je les laisse parce que c'est des
adultes responsables faire leur propre
négociation
et après là il y a un paramètre qui est
incontrôlable c'est la qualité du
négociateur je suis pas responsable du
sujet c'est que je pense que de même
situation faite par deux personnes
différentes aboutissent pas même
résultat et ça c'est ma vision
personnelle du sujet après sur pour en
revenir à votre point
est-ce que ça ça peut engendrer des
situations de pénurie
en tout cas ou de moindre accès oui je
le pense oui moi j'ai deux exemples
récents un produit
entrant sur le marché
et en plus un peu inattendu sur sa
conclusion parce que firme française
développement français fait la demande
de clinicien français pour avoir une
solution thérapeutique alors qui est pas
une révolution dans dans les produits
qu'elle contient mais en tout cas dans
sa galénique et son mode de dispensation
c'est pour des enfants donc c'est une
solution pédiatrique dans une situation
où le traitement demande à réveiller son
enfant jeune trois fois par nuit pour
lui faire ingurgiter quelque chose qui
ne préparation hospitalière qu'il a pas
du tout envie de prendre parce que c'est
un goût moi j'ai testé moi je pense que
je serais pas très compliant au sujet
donc ça industriel en fait fait un
développement fait des études des mondes
que sa solution
est intéressante d'un point de vue
innovation duquel
et ça reste un point d'interrogation
pour moi en conclusion de négociation on
arrive à un point de proposition du
Comité et qui sont liées à ces critères
de fixation du prix qui sont des
critères publiques et ceux de l'accord
cadre qui sont en dessous du prix de
revient industriel
donc là effectivement
la question de lancer un produit qui va
vous coûter de l'argent à chaque botte
que vous allez vendre elle est un peu
compliquée quand même et là on parle pas
de produits à
5000 euros par mois on parle de produits
de coût de traitement à 5 7000 euros par
an
et
le comité mais à raison par rapport en
fait aux éléments dont il a disposition
il dit oui mais le critère industriel
n'est pas un critère de fixation du prix
petite modulation avec
l'article 65 quand même du PLFSS ça
reste marginal quand même oui mais c'est
pas prévu marginal dans la loi ça reste
marginale
[Musique]
c'est que le comité dirait même si on
arrive au point de revient industriel
ensuite moi je ne suis pas garant d'une
quelconque marche que vous devez
réaliser
et donc oui effectivement même si on
arrive au point de revient industriel
plus ça marche de distribution une
entreprise qui fait 5 ou 10 ans de
recherche pour arriver à mettre sur le
marché un produit qui lui
potentiellement lui coûte marginalement
de l'argent
c'est une situation compliquée elles
sont pas très fréquentes mais elles
existent ces situations
et à l'inverse moi j'ai rencontré une
situation où on un laboratoire un
produit qui est un produit de
prescription régulier il fait appel à
des façonniers français ont un qui est
très dépendant en fait de ce produit se
retrouve dans une situation où
l'augmentation de la cascade des prix de
production coût des matières premières
amène à avoir un prix de revient par
unité qui est au-dessus de son prix
régulé et pose la question au comité de
est-ce qu'on peut se décontraindre en
fait de ce prix régulé l'augmenter pour
assurer une pérennité la réponse du
comité parce que ces règles sont faites
ainsi c'est maintenant que vous avez des
comparateurs
donc on ne peut pas renégocier
la résultante c'est qu'il y a mise en
péril au moins d'un des façonniers mais
ça on n'y peut rien parce que quoi qu'il
arrive que l'industriel fasse le choix
de maintenir ce produit ou de le dé
rembourser il y aura un impact sur les
volumes donc il y aura un impact sur la
production
et donc il y a des fois mais moi je
critique pas le travail du comité je dis
juste qu'il a des fois des règles qui ne
lui permettent pas en fait de prendre en
compte des éléments qui à certains
moments permettrait de décontracter un
peu ce type de discussion
tout à fait après il y a des objectifs à
gérer entre la transparence la
reproductibilité des relations
contractuelles et ne pas donner le
sentiment que
l'essentiel de la négociation se fait
qu'elles sur quelque chose qui n'est pas
de référence quoi donc c'est un peu ça
le sujet il y a c'est à dire qu'il y a
les deux les deux plans dans le premier
exemple que j'ai évoqué
moi je trouve quand même un peu étonnant
sachant qu'il y a un membre de quoi la
DGV est représenter au niveau du comité
économique la DGCCRF aussi qu'on arrive
une fille à faire une proposition qui
soit en dessous d'un prix de revient
industriel qui sur lequel qui a été
documenté
me laisse un peu perplexe alors ce
produit rassurez-vous en fait il
continue à être à être distribué sur le
marché grâce à une autorisation d'accès
précoce qui a été maintenu et qui a été
une solution qui était trouvée sorte de
rustine on n'arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord il y a ce dispositif vous en
avez bénéficié on continue à vous en
faire bénéficier sa régulation est moins
pénalisante que celle qui aurait été la
commercialisation est-ce que pour
l'affirme CP Rennes en termes de vision
et d'investissement pour le futur et
pour son directeur financier je suis pas
très sûr
on se focalise beaucoup sur les API et
moi sur les formes galéniques par
exemple qui pourtant peuvent être de
l'innovation et c'est un vrai sujet quoi
surtout si elle permet effectivement de
l'observance d'un traitement qui ne
l'est pas c'est ça l'observant c'est un
élément qui apprend en compte dans la
CMR on est d'accord monsieur Clément
alors j'ai évoqué précédemment nos
travaux et notre accompagnement d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs de l'industrie
pharmaceutique sur les produits
innovants et donc à ce titre on
intervient souvent dans des
problématiques de stratégie de lancement
ou d'accompagnement au lancement
la problématique d'accès ou de prix
est une des problématiques parmi
d'autres des considérations marketing
des considérations d'affaires médicales
des circonstitutions de supply voilà
la plupart de cet accompagnement se fait
auprès des équipes globales
et donc la considération
franco-française est souvent une parmi
tant d'autres et je vous rappelle que le
poids de la France dans le marché
mondial de la suite de l'industrie
pharmaceutique et uniquement de 3 %
et donc nous ne sommes pas directement
impliqués dans des problématiques
spécifiques et techniques de fixation
des prix ou de négociation avec le CEPS
ou comme on ne l'est pas avec lilvig en
Allemagne ou la Nice en Angleterre
par contre nous prenons en considération
c'est dynamique de prix pour aligner les
timings et les séquences de lancement
reconnaître cette histoire de référence
pricing qui peut exister au niveau
européen et qui peut jouer dans les
séquences de lancement etc voilà le je
dirais le sujet le plus proche qu'on a
de
la problématique de fixation des prix et
de négociation
moi j'ai noté deux questions madame à la
deuxième qui était sur la à ton travail
sur la fixation de prix ou des éléments
de négociation là
non je ne pense pas à ma connaissance
non nous n'avons pas été impliqué sur
des éléments liés à des prix de
médicaments
sur votre première question qui était
sur les stocks
si j'ai bien compris là oui nous avons
nous avons des travaux en cours
précisément autour de et qui sont liés
en fait
entre autres pénurie et aux ruptures
qu'on a pu constater et qui sont
également liés aux conséquences de la
crise covid ou un certain nombre
d'industriels et en l'occurrence un
client s'est rendu compte de la
complexité de sa chaîne
d'approvisionnement du manque de
transparence qui pouvait exister et du
manque de solidité potentiellement dans
certains nombres d'éléments et on nous a
demandé d'aider à accompagner à rendre
cette chaîne d'approvisionnement plus
robuste avec un objectif très important
qui est de diminuer les les ruptures et
les pénuries parce que celles-ci ont un
coût important et d'augmenter le niveau
de service à destination de ses clients
et à destination de ces des patients
donc sur ce sujet là oui nous avons une
nous avons un projet
juste pour pour comprendre donc on ne
sait pas focaliser sur les aspects de
stock on s'est focalisé vraiment sur les
aspects de bout en bout de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement donc comment est-ce
que par exemple on utilise des outils
digitaux ou analytiques ou de la donnée
on ira beaucoup mieux anticiper des
évolutions de demandes potentielles sur
des produits qui sont très différents et
ensuite comment est-ce que on revient en
arrière de manière à avoir une chaîne
d'approvisionnement la plus fluide
jusqu'au site de production donc on
accompagne des équipes de manière très
opérationnelle à mettre en place un
certain nombre de d'outils de systèmes
qui permettent de fluidifier de rendre
plus solides cette chaîne
d'approvisionnement avec encore une fois
l'objectif de
de mettre à disposition des patients les
produits en temps et en heure et en
volume nécessaire
donc ça signifie que c'est un travail
qui peut donc qui va aboutir et donc qui
est pas que pensez-vous du fait que on
mette en place le travail pour une liste
limitative de médicaments au plan
européen et français de façon à
sécuriser
l'arrivée de médicaments qui sont dit
critiques c'est à dire à la fois fort
risque de pénurie de façon structurelle
ou conjoncturelle mais aussi qui ont un
service médical rendu tel que ils sont
essentiels et que toute pénurie et
préjudiciable du point de la santé
publique je pense que c'est un élément
critique et important qui peut être
effectivement pris en compte par les
industriels tout à fait
donc sur la question des stocks sur le
la question du du médicament
et on mentionnait tout à l'heure les
hôpitaux on a eu l'occasion de
travailler mais de manière je dirais
très
spécifique avec des acteurs hospitaliers
quand on intervient par exemple dans des
blocs opératoires dans une unité de
soins sur la bonne adéquation des stocks
déportés de manière à s'assurer que les
personnels voilà et ce qu'il faut etc
donc je pense qu'on est assez loin de ce
qui nous de ce qui nous occupe donc ça
c'est le premier élément j'ai pas
mémoire mais je pourrais encore une fois
vérifier si on a été
travaillé sur des logiques des stocks
plus larges au niveau d'un hôpital mais
encore une fois je suis pas sûr que ce
soit ça qui m'occupe du côté vraiment
industriel
etc
là je ne sais pas à ma connaissance j'ai
pas identifié encore une fois dans la
liste de projets qu'on est en train
d'assembler de sujets
mais mais on vous fera parvenir cette
liste là
en fin de semaine
on verra si effectivement il y a des
choses mais à ma connaissance il n'y en
a pas voilà pour ce qui est des aspects
de prix
donc effectivement mes collègues
accompagnent et je reprendrai à peu près
les termes que Monsieur Plantevin a
utilisé accompagne des stratégies de
produits
souvent à l'échelon global
et le plus souvent sur des problèmes
globales
et donc je ne sais pas dans quelle
mesure le prix est vraiment une question
spécifique sur laquelle on s'interroge
et donc ça éventuellement dans le cas
d'une stratégie globale c'est
potentiellement le cas économique quand
même bien sûr après si vous voulez sur
l'aspect de stratégie de fixation du
prix etc je suis pas sûr je ne sais pas
dans quelle mesure on rentre vraiment
sur ces considérations là et encore une
fois comme les et Monsieur Plantevin on
est on est le plus souvent sur les
premiers globales et donc la France
représente
qu'un élément limité de du périmètre et
enfin on n'a pas d'intervention directe
auprès du CPS et on pas d'intervention
directe dans ce type de négociation ça
fait partie des je dirais des règles
qu'on se fixe de ne pas intervenir
directement dans ce type de choses
et donc pour compléter je pense que je
rejoins que disent mes collègues le les
travaux qu'on mène dans les lancements
de nouveaux produits sont des lancements
qui consistent à déterminer les
conditions de succès de l'entrée de ces
produits dans les dans les différentes
géographies de manière généralement
globale
le prix est naturellement un des
éléments clés d'un modèle économique
malgré tous les travaux
cette expertise c'est une expertise
assez spécifique qui nécessite une vraie
connaissance locale de la réalité
réglementaire de ces prix nos travaux
consistent plutôt à déterminer tous les
facteurs de risque ou les facteurs de
succès de lancement de ces produits donc
on est moins amené à travailler de
manière spécifique sur sur les sujets
locaux on n'a pas naturellement
d'intervention en direct en direct avec
avec le CEPS néanmoins sur le deuxième
question qui est sur la stabilisation
des chaînes d'approvisionnement
travaillant naturellement avec
l'ensemble de l'écosystème on a noté
cette dégradation avant le covid déjà et
après le covid
sur ces conditions de disponibilité de
matière sur certains choix stratégiques
qui ont été faits par des fournisseurs
en préhistoriques vous mentionnez les
principes actifs
naturellement la crise a continué à
renforcer la complexité mais elle était
déjà prégnante avant et donc aujourd'hui
là où je rejoins mais mes collègues
c'est que le ces enjeux de disponibilité
de lutte contre les ruptures
d'approvisionnement sont deviennent des
sujets majeurs pour les laboratoires et
les industriels dans la mesure où en
fait c'est des situations qui pénalisent
tout le monde le patient d'abord mais
aussi ces industriels qui ont pas la
possibilité de venir le livrer en temps
un ordre qui est derrière susceptible
d'être pénalisé
ça signifie quand même que dans
toutes vos interpellations vous utilisez
des comparateurs de prix du médicament
de pays API
pour conseiller alors
spécifiquement non par contre la
fixation d'un généralement lorsqu'on
fait des lancements de produits il y a
des comparatifs qui sont faits pas pays
par pays mais des comparatifs qui sont
faits par rapport à des molécules qui
peuvent être similaires pour avoir une
idée de ce que pourrait être l'ordre de
grandeur d'un prix
nous témoignent du fait que le prix du
médicament en France serait où est en
tout cas ça dépend
c'est comme le fait du piano n'est-ce
pas et donc en fait
serait inférieur pour la plupart des
médicaments matures
et en fait
c'est un des éléments d'arbitrage pour
distribuer ou non ou dimensionner la
taille des stocks qui sont envoyés qui
sont destinés à la France en situation
de tension même avant la pénurie voilà
donc est-ce que c'est ces éléments là
sont des éléments sur lesquels on vous
interpelle pour justifier d'un nouvel de
la création d'un nouveau médicament
est-ce que la France est considérée
comme aidante pour les thérapies
innovantes du point de vue financier ou
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres pays qui sont
réputés pour l'être plus ça fait partie
des éléments j'imagine quand même
je crois que le cirque on évoquait
précédemment et un atout indéniable de
la France pour attirer un certain nombre
d'investissements moins sur des outils
industriels et de production mais plus
sur l'innovation
que ce soit le développement des
nouvelles technologies absolument
je partage après ou le cire peut être un
petit peu
[Musique]
ambiguë je pense qu'il est très
intéressant pour que ceux qui sont déjà
présents qui ont déjà en fait fait un
investissement et veulent le compléter
est-ce qu'il est lisible en fait pour
ceux qui voudraient faire une décision
d'arbitrage sur un endroit sur un autre
je suis pas très sûr après sur la
question des prix sur la question des
prix internationaux effectivement en
termes d'innovation
avec l'accord cadre on a une garantie de
prix européen donc la question se pose
beaucoup moins sur les produits matures
l'exemple que j'évoquais préalablement
oui effectivement il y a un problème qui
se pose c'est quand le produit en
question son prix deux fois inférieur en
France à tous les autres marchés
européens
et donc en plus de perdre de l'argent
l'industrielle est confronté aux
problèmes de d'exportation parallèle
tous les stocks qui reçoit alors je suis
pas un spécialiste de la distribution et
je sais pas si c'est au niveau des
grossistes au niveau des répartiteurs il
y en a un fruit qui repart vers
l'étranger parce qu'en fait le prix la
différence de prix entre la France et
l'étranger permet de faire une marche
exponentielle qui ne fait pas
l'industrielle donc ça c'est dans le
circuit de distribution mais oui
effectivement ça peut être un frein
majeur à partir du moment où on sait que
si on a une quantité limitée d'un
produit parce qu'il y a des problèmes de
prod c'est plus rentable de les fournir
un marché
qui rapporte de l'argent par rapport à
un marché qui nous rapporte pas c'est
juste une décision de d'hyper
rationalité de gestion en entreprise en
fait et sur les produits nature oui je
pense qu'il y a des sujets
oui quelques précisions encore peut-être
que sur
igvia quand on les a auditionnés ils
nous ont quand même dit que les prix
étaient assez visibles à fixation des
prix donc est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça et je vais je vais comme le
temps tourne je vais être amené à poser
la dernière question les deux dernières
questions un moment donné donc vous avez
dit que les uns les autres il y avait
pas vous aviez vos conseils n'avaient
pas entraîné des délocalisations
partielles de technologie et des
productions pour de motifs déficience
parce que j'avais reprécisé ma question
mais je vois quand même et notamment
issue des travaux de BCG
au niveau de des décisions stratégiques
de Sanofi donc vous avez conseillé et
notamment concernant un plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi
et bien vous auriez travaillé sur la
rationalisation du nombre de produits
distribués par le groupe 300 familles de
produits étude 23000 références et là
c'est un lien direct avec les pénuries
de médicaments parce que c'est à partir
du moment où vos conseils entraînent des
suppressions de postes et donc un
affaiblissement on va dire de la
production vous comprendrez bien qu'il y
a une incidence monsieur vient spa sur
les les pénuries de médicaments futurs
donc j'aimerais avoir vous concernant
une réponse précise et une réponse aussi
précise au niveau de makinset puisque je
vois que sur la période 2015-2019 c'est
le cabinet conseil McKinsey qui a pris
la relève donc est-ce que vous avez été
dans les mêmes logiques que votre
confrère si je puis dire enfin ma
dernière question s'adresse à tout le
monde c'est sur le modèle économique du
médicament innovant on voit pour aller
vite que Big Pharma
à une une tactique finalement où il va
préférer favoriser le rachat de startup
pour pouvoir profiter en fait de niche
et pour avoir moins de frais dans
moins de frais dans la dans tout ce qui
est recherche
il va prendre en quelque sorte le
produit enfin l'innovation telle qu'elle
a été faite par ces startups et ensuite
donc une fois que l'innovation est faite
ils vont ils vont
se charger du reste donc je voudrais
savoir si les uns et les autres vous
êtes dans cette dans cette logique
est-ce que vous avez conseillé un
certain nombre d'industriels pour aller
effectivement vers cette logique
économique qui apparaît comme plus
rentable et qui en même temps privilégie
des médicaments innovants qui sont
utiles mais qui sont très onéreux
et parfois qui peuvent couper l'herbe
sous pied à des médicaments matures
la question sur le PSE et la
rationalisation je crois des
portefeuilles de produits sur le PSE
effectivement nous avons travaillé sur
un à la mise en oeuvre d'un PSA en 2019
je n'étais pas moi-même impliqué sur la
sur la mise en oeuvre de ce de ce PSE
donc je pourrai pas vous dire exactement
ni ce qu'on a fait précisément ce que je
sais c'est que on a aidé à la mise en
œuvre à la mise en forme d'un certain
nombre d'éléments dans le cadre de ce
PSE et de décision qui avait été prise
par Sanofi
sur le
et comme l'a dit la Présidente c'est
tout à fait normal que vous n'ayez pas
toutes les réponses mais par contre sur
cette question précise qu'il y a des
incidences par rapport à la production
de médicaments comme pour les autres
questions d'ailleurs on vous demande de
nous faire des réponses écrites
je l'ai noté sur même chose je vous
ferai une réponse écrite précise sur la
rationalisation des produits parce que
même chose c'est pas quelque chose dont
j'ai le souvenir et je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit lié par ailleurs à ce à ce
PSE ma seule observation personnelle
c'est pour avoir travaillé sur des
réflexions autour de la rationalisation
de portefeuille c'est que la
rationalisation de portefeuille peut
permettre justement la réduction des
pénuries parce qu'on ne diminue pas
nécessairement le nombre de produits
mais on peut diminuer des familles de
référence au sein d'un même produit et
donc un des problèmes auxquels la
plupart des industriels sont confrontées
c'est la multiplication des références
sur un marché mais aussi de manière
globale et donc des portefeuilles
extrêmement complexes pas simplement en
termes de produits mais surtout en
termes de référence et donc un des
objectifs c'est de se dire qu'on va
diminuer le nombre de références de
manière à être beaucoup plus capable de
les produire et de les ensuite de les
distribuer au patients donc je peux pas
répondre sur le fond précisément sur la
question que vous me posez mais avec mon
œil d'expert et pour avoir participé à
un certain nombre de discussions sur ce
sujet là j'aurais aussi tendance à dire
que la
décomplexification d'un portefeuille
peut avoir des effets extrêmement
bénéfiques si je penchaîné si vous
voulez sur le sur votre question sur le
sur la recherche moi je dirais que le
là c'est une industrie
où effectivement je crois que les
statistiques disent que 60 70 % des
médicaments lancés viennent de biotech
de petite taille c'est une industrie qui
est très ouverte sur l'innovation
externe parce que un des éléments et que
innover dans des plus petites structures
et parfois plus plus facile ou en tout
cas ça c'est montré comme étant plus
facile ce que je dirais c'est que en
sans avoir travaillé directement sur ce
sujet là au cours des dernières années
en tout cas même chose dans les
discussions qu'on a pu avoir avec un
certain nombre de nos clients faire de
l'innovation externe ne veut pas dire
diminuer l'innovation interne au
contraire je pense que ce qui est très
important pour rattraper sur un certain
nombre d'acquisition par exemple c'est
qu'en interne il faut absolument des
compétences de manière à être capable
d'évaluer la science qui provient de
l'extérieur et que les choix
scientifiques au moment de ces
acquisitions où on suit au moment du
développement des des produits qui
peuvent être achetés ou bien la SNC
puisse être fait de manière très très
efficace donc même chose je n'opposerai
pas nécessairement le fait que
l'innovation soit externe avec des
pertes de compétences ou des pertes de
souveraineté je pense qu'il existe une
complémentarité forte en travaux des une
recherche interne forte et en même temps
en allant chercher une innovation
qu'elle soit interne ou bien ou bien
externe
écoutez notre servant pas Sanofi je n'ai
pas les informations donc je ne sais pas
le travail qu'on a qu'on aurait pu faire
ensuite de celui de BCG sur la
rationalisation du portefeuille donc je
on va vous apporter des éléments
complémentaires évidemment par écrit et
sur cette question effectivement du
modèle d'innovation
et de bascule d'une innovation fortement
interne une part d'innovation très
externe
il me semble que
l'industrie pharmaceutique sur les 50 ou
60 dernières années a été une industrie
qui s'est basée sur l'innovation ça fait
partie de son modèle je dirais de
développement et de création de valeur
cœur
voilà pour cette audition de la
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie de
médicaments qui se tient au Sénat ce
printemps et qui en a c'est conclusions
au mois de juin n'hésitez pas à lire les
articles de notre rédaction sur le site
de publics.fr très belle suite des
programmes sur notre antenne
[Musique]